네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다 어 제가
오늘은 임대 시세 조사하는 방법과
그다음 임대 잘 마치는 방법에 대해서
좀 영상을 찍어 보려고 합니다 어
최근에 좀 경기가 안 좋아지면서 좀
공실률이 되게 높아졌어요 그래서
임대에 대한 되게 이런 고민이 되게
많으실 것 같은데 빌딩 투자할 때
가장 중요한게 임대라고 생각을 합니다
그래서 보통은 빌딩 매입할 때 그냥
대지 평당 얼마 뭐 이렇게 해 가지고
가격이 싸니까 이렇게
매입하시나요 임대 시세 조사하는게
무엇보다 되게 중요합니다 그래서
나중에 임대를 얼마에 맞출 수 있는지
여기 지역은 공실률이 한 어느 정도
되는지 파악하는게 가장 중요하기
때문에 여러분들 지금이 영상 어
놓치지 말고 꼭 보셨으면 좋겠습니다
어 우선은 임대시 조사하는 방법인데
가장 좀 편하게 볼 수 있는 거는
네이버 부동산을 참고하시면 좋을 거
같아요 만약에 내가 이제 상가나
사무실로 마친다고 하면 여기 탭이
있거든요 그래서 여기 탭을 클릭하시면
요렇게 나와 있는 것들을 파악할 수
있어요 제가 만약에 이제 이쪽 지역에
건물을 산다라고 하면 여기는 상가보다
오피스가 좀 많거든요 그래서 오피스로
검색을 한 다음에 뭐 거래 방식은
월세 그리고 만약에 내가 여기다
건물을 만든 다음에 뭐 통임대 주고
싶다라고 하면 연면적이 그래도 좀 뭐
예를 들어서 100평 이상이다라고
하면 이렇게 검색하면 이렇게 좀
줄어들죠 여기 인근에 이렇게 통임대
나와 있는 그런 건물들이 있어요
그래서 세 4천만 원에 나와 있고
전용이 250평 있니다 그럼 4천만
원에 250평 하면 전용 면적당 한
16만 원 정도 그리고 여기 건물에
또 확인하셔야 될게 뭐 엘리베이터나
이런게 있는지도 확인을 하셔야 돼요
그래서 또 몇 개 좀 더 볼게요
요것도 통임대 나와 있는 거고 건물이
되게 화려하네요 7천만 원에 이건
전용 면적이 안 나와 있긴 한데 임대
면적이 한 17만 원요 정도 됩니다
그래서 요거는 금액이 좀 비싸게 나와
있네요 옥상에 이렇게 풀이 있는
건물은 되게 오랜만에 보는데 좀
특이한 그런 건물인 거 같습니다
그리고 여기도 보면은 요런데도 통임대
나와 있고 그래서 5천만 원에 것도
이제 전용 면적이 나와 있지 않은데
어 임대 면적당 한 15만 원 정도
가장 정확한 건 전용 면적당
계산하는게 좀 좋은데 지금 아까 보신
것처럼 임대 면적으로 나온 경우가
많거든요 그래서 두 가지 다
비교하시면 좋을 것 같아요 전용
면적당 금액이랑 임대 면적당 금액
근데 임대 면적당 금액이 좀 여기
올린 거 중에서는 그나마 낫기 때문에
임대 면적당 기준으로 중점적으로 좀
보시면 될 거 같습니다 뭐 제가 봤을
때는 대략 한 임대 면적 당으로 봤을
때 한 10 10만 원 중반 뭐이
정도에 마칠 수 있을 것 같아요
그래서 여러분들이 만약에 이쪽 지역에
뭔가 개발 행위를 한다라고 하면 그
면적 대비해서 이거를 좀 대입해
보시면 나중에 인대를 대략 한 어느
정도 마칠 수 있겠다 이런게 좀
보이거든요 그래서 여러분들이 이걸
파악하는게 제 중요해요 그리고 이런
경우도 있어요 매각을 하기 위해서
임대료를 되게 높게 책정한 건물들도
있거든요 뭐 리스백 조건으로 되게
비싸게 맞춰 놓고 비싸게 매각하려고
하는 그런 건물들도 있기 때문에
여러분들이이 임대 시세를 조사하는게
되게 중요한 요소입니다 여러분들이
이렇게 좀 네이버 부동산 들어가서
주변에 지금 내가 뭐 예를 들어
통임대 마칠 거면 통임대 매물이 몇
개 정도 올라와 있고 내가 이거를
개발했을 때이 건물이 좀 경쟁력이 있
있을지 뭐 이런 거를 좀 미리 사전에
분석을 해야 돼요 이쪽 지역 같은
경우에는 그래도 통임대 매물들이 꽤
있었어요 나중에 여러분들이 좀 통임대
줄 때이 건물에 대한 뭔가 장점이
있을지 어 이런 것들을 좀 분석하실
필요가 있습니다 뭐 가장 쉬운 거는이
네이버 부동산 들어가서 이렇게 좀
찾아보는게 제일 중요해요 만약에 내가
개별 임대 준다라고 하면 1층이
얼마에 나와 있는지 뭐 지하가 얼마에
나와 있는지 그리고 2층이 얼마에
나와 있는지 그 이상에 얼마에 나와
있 는지 뭐 이런 것들을 엑셀로
정리하던 아니면 표로 좀 정리한
다음에 하면 평균적으로 금액이
나오거든요 그래서 그걸 기준으로 한
어느 정도 맞출 수 있겠다 어 이런
감이 오실 겁니다 그거에 따라서
투자를 하냐마냐 결정이 되거든요 임대
수익 가지고 어느 정도 수익이
나와야지 투자 가치가 있는 거기
때문에 그거를 계산하는게 좀 중요한
부분이다 어 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다 임대 시세 파악하는 방법은
어이 정도로 하면 될 거 같고
두 번째로 임대 잘 마치는 방법인데
엄청 뭐 특별한 능력이 있다기보다는
많이 알리는게 제일 중요하거든요 여기
지역을 찾는 사람한테 많이 알리는게
제일 중요한데 일단은 보통은 현수막을
많이 설치를 하죠 건물에 지나다니
사람들이 보고 전화올 확률이 좀 있고
그 두 번째로는 그 일대 업체한테 다
연락을 해요 어 이쪽 지역에 뭐
리모델링이나 신축한 건물이 있다
그래서 뭐이 면적인 뭐 임대료 한요
정도 된다라고 다 연락을 합니다 주변
임차인 분들한테 그래서 혹시 이전할
생각이 있는지 그게 좀 확률이 되게
높아요 좀 잘 아는 지역이고 그
지역에 있으려고 하니까 만약에 내가
뭐 청담동에 건물을 만들어서 임대를
줄 거다라고 하면 그 지역에 있는
임차인들 테는 다 컨택해서 홍보를
많이 합니다 강남 같은 경우에는 공실
클럽이라는 데를 좀 많이 이용을 해요
공실 클럽의 일단 장점이 강남 1대에
있는 부동산들이 다 공실 클럽으로
많이 하거든요 그래서 그걸 하는 이유
중에 하나가 임대 수수료를 같이
공유해요 내가 임대인한테 0.5
6이라는 0.7 정도 받으면 0.3을
그 임차인
부동산한방 공식 클러 하면 너무 좋죠
원래는 그 임대인 수수료는 안 봤는데
만약에 전속 매물 같은 경우에이
임대인 수수료도 같이 쉐어를 하기
때문에이 임차인을 데리고 있는이
부동산은 공실 클럽을 통해서 좀
이렇게 진행하는 경우가 많습니다요
임금뿐만 아니라 저희가 마치고 싶은
업종들 있잖아요 저희가 최근에 맞친
것 중에 하나가 선능 이에 있는
건물을 저희가 1층을 커피숍을
맞췄어요 그 태안로 일대에서 그
커피숍으로 되게 유명한 업체였고
그래서 저희가 그 업체한테가 가지고
이렇게 자료랑 해서 보내 드리니까 좀
확장할 계획이 있다라고 해서 최근에
맞췄는데 이거와 비슷하게 내가 마치고
싶은 업종들 있잖아요 그 업종들 좀
리스트와 해 가지고 이런 자료들을 좀
보내는 것도 좀 방법입니다 그래서 좀
이렇게 임차인을 찾는게 되게 좀
중요한 거 같아요 커피 일층 커피숍이
나머지 뭐 병원이라는 뭐 병원이다
하면 그 인근 1대 병원에는 다
뿌려야 돼요 제한설 다 뿌리고 그
인근 부동산 당연한 거고 공실클럽
당연히 올려야 되고 현수막도 당연히
걸어야 되고 어찌됐든 진행할 때
수수료를 좀 아까워 하면 안 되는 거
같아요 만약에 내가 전속을 부동산을
줄 거다라고 하면 그 전속 부동산이랑
같이 얘기해야 될게 그냥 임차인
데리고 오는 부동산에 같이 수술료
쉐어 하자라고 해서 수수료라는 이런
걸 좀 아끼지 않고 좀 이렇게
진행하는게 제일 중요한 거 같고 내
건물을 많이 알리고 그 일대에서이
건물이 나왔다는 거는 좀 잘 하고
그리고 또 중요한게 렌트 풀이나 이런
협상 같은 거를 많이 해 줄 필요가
있는 거 같아 요즘 같은 경우에 좀
임대가 좀 쉽지 않기 때문에 트 프리
기간이라는 뭐 이런 기타 조건들 같은
경우에는 너그럽게 할 필요가 있는 거
같습니다 그래서 좀 정리해 볼게요
빌딩 투자할 때 가장 중요한게 임대
시세를 조사하는게 제일 중요한데 임대
시세 조사하려면 네이버 부동산을
참고해서 사무실이라는 상가의 임대료를
파악하는게 제일 중요하고 그 파악한
건물이 뭐 엘리베이터라는 뭐 최근에
뭐 이렇게 디벨롭 한 그런 건물인지
내가 임대 줄 건물 컨디션이랑
비슷한지를 체크를 하셔야 되고 임대를
여러분들이 진행을 하실 때 뭐
현수막뿐만 아니라 뭐 공실 클럽
그리고 이제 주변에 있는 특히 그
인근에 있는 임차인들 테 제안서는
이런 건 당연히 보내야 되고 그리고
내가 넣고 싶은 업종들 테는 다
제안서를 보내야 됩니다 마지막으로 그
수수료라는 이런 부분을 잘 챙겨
준다라고 얘기를 해야지이 건물이 다른
건물보다 좀 좋은 조건에 좋은
임차인에 어 임대를 마칠 수 있는
확률이 되게 높아집니다네 그래서
여러분들이 부분을 기억하셨다가 공실
없는 건물로 만드셨으면 좋겠습니다
정말 요즘에 금리도 금리지표 상항이
너무 좀 좋지 않거든요 그래서
여러분들 빌딩 투자하실 때 단순하게
뭐 평당 얼마 싸게 사 가지고 뭐
어떻게 개발을 하겠다 그냥 그거보다도
이거를 이렇게 만들어서 어떻게 세일즈
하고 어떻게 차별화를 두고 어떻게
임차인이 좋게 만들어서 임대를 줄
건지 어이 부분을 좀 중점적으로
생각해서 나중에 건물을 뭐 신축이나
리모델링 했을 때 공실이 되게 장기간
나면 안 되잖아요이 부분을
기억하셨다가 빌딩 투자하실 때 좀
도움이 되셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서
오늘 영상이 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다